after her breakout role on gossip girl
taylor momsen gave up acting to sing
with her band the pretty reckless
but you might not know what else she's
been up to here's what she's been up to
lately
taylor momsen entered the entertainment
industry at a very young age well before
she was old enough to make a decision
about it for herself
throughout her career momsen has
revealed that she had mixed feelings
about her upbringing
when asked about her childhood momsen
would sometimes state that becoming an
actress was her choice and that her
parents simply helped her find
opportunities but later comments
revealed a very different picture
for instance momsen said in an interview
with revolver my parents signed me up
with ford modeling at the age of two
no two-year-old wants to be working but
i had no choice
my whole life i was in and out of school
i didn't have friends
i was working constantly and i didn't
have a real life after moving to new
york to film gossip girl and finishing
high school early
momson stated that while she loved her
parents she was now legally responsible
for herself
and could enjoy more freedom and
independence it seems like momsen was
pushed into the spotlight before she was
ready and now her career is in her own
hands
when taylor momsen landed the role of
jenny humphrey on gossip girl it was her
big break
are there skins on these almonds fix it
in a timely fashion otherwise you're all
going as the real housewives of new
jersey for halloween but some of the
actors who worked with her on the show
weren't
impressed behind the scenes in later
seasons momson was appearing on screen
less and less
and tim gunn hinted at why this was
after guest starring on the show
in an interview with e news gunn who had
played a mentor to jenny on the series
said of momson what a diva she was
pathetic she couldn't remember her lines
and she didn't even have that many
i thought to myself why are we being
held hostage by this brat
while the team behind gossip girls
stated that the air time for momsen's
character was being cut for creative
reasons
it seemed likely that after working on
the series for a few years momsen was
getting frustrated with acting
perhaps gunn's characterization of her
behavior on set was unfair
but momsen was definitely ready to move
on besides i'm leaving like where i
wanted
although momson was a successful actress
she had always secretly dreamed of
making music
and after working on gossip girl she
realized that she didn't enjoy being in
front of the camera
she had been writing her own song since
she was a child and she wished she could
start her own band
one day she realized that she didn't
have to act anymore if she didn't want
to
as momsen told cosmopolitan when i
realized i could actually make my
decisions
it was a very strange feeling it was
like if i don't have to do this thing
that i don't enjoy anymore or i don't
know if i ever really did then i'm not
gonna do it anymore
because this is my life and i want to
live it and enjoy it if i can
she decided to focus on following her
passion for music instead
in her early years with the pretty
reckless taylor momsen faced some
obstacles
being a young woman in a male-dominated
genre she wasn't always taken seriously
but for a while she tried to ignore the
phenomenon of sexism in the music
industry
she was branded as a wild child for her
onstage antics and there were doubts
about her authenticity as an artist
later she realized that some of this
criticism was aimed at her simply for
being a teenage girl
momsen said in an interview with louder
sound i was so in denial for so long
about sexism but as i've gotten older i
realized it exists i've recognized it
more as i've gotten older that there is
a boys club when it comes to rock and
roll
and it is a struggle to break into that
and be accepted and treated with the
same respect as if you were a man
today she's more comfortable and
confident in her own skin
i am a female and i am psyched that
people are
liking it opening for sound garden in
2017 was one of the highlights of
momson's career
she never would have imagined that she
would appear at the same concert as
chris cornell
soundgarden's lead vocalist and one of
her musical heroes but tragedy struck
when momson received the news that
cornell had died by suicide
she told spin i was there that last
night in detroit
i talked to him at night i gave him a
hug and said goodbye
when i wake up to that news the next
morning it just went from the most
elating experience to the one of the
most devastating
after a few more performances momson
decided to put her own bands to her on
hold
she explained i couldn't grieve and
continue to get on stage every night and
pretend put on this big rock show like
everything was okay
months after chris cornell's death
taylor momsen and her bandmates were
finally ready to start recording music
again
but shortly after they decided to begin
working on a new album momson got a
heartbreaking phone call
and learned that their producer and her
close friend kato kondwala had been
killed in a motorcycle accident momsen
told metro
he was so much more than a producer he
was a fifth member of the band and my
best friend in the world
i can't explain our relationship but it
was so immensely close
after losing two people who meant so
much to her mumson tried to find a way
to numb her pain
and told the daily beast i wouldn't say
rock bottom but i was getting close to
that
i was in this hole of depression and was
not well mentally
momsen says that during this period of
her life she did not want to engage with
the outside world at
all and she spent most of her time at
home rather than turning to others for
help she tried to isolate
herself even though her bandmates lived
nearby
in the midst of her grief taylor momsen
found that even listening to music made
her feel worse the singer explained to
illinois entertainer
i got to a point where i couldn't listen
to music and that was really sad for
me if i put on any music which has
always brought me such solace and hope
and light it would bring back some sort
of memory which was too much for me to
handle
or too painful so i didn't have my
outlet which had always been there for
me
at the time momsen couldn't even bear
the thought of listening to her favorite
artists let alone writing new songs
eventually she began to pull herself out
of her depression by returning to her
favorite band
the beatles when she was able to listen
to soundgarden again she knew it was
finally time to pick up her own guitar
gossip girl fans are getting excited
about an upcoming reboot of the series
naturally the audience who tuned in for
the show's original run are wondering
which cast members might make an
appearance
fans of momsen who were introduced to
her through gossip girl are wondering if
she'll be coming back for a guest
appearance but the musician has no plans
to return to acting
momsen told the daily beast i don't have
any plans to be any part of the reboot i
never really watched the show when it
was on the air i don't really ever like
watching myself it makes me
uncomfortable
however momsen is curious about how the
reboot will handle technology
as the characters always had to have the
latest phones to spread gossip
she revealed that she's considering
watching the reboot just to see how the
writers tackle this topic
there was a time when taylor momsen
would reliably pop up in the tabloids
and gossip magazines but today she has
no real interest in chasing fame
while she loves her career as a musician
she doesn't care to put her personal
life in the spotlight
momsen revealed to people once there was
paparazzi outside my door i learned very
quickly to ignore all of it
fame is a fleeting thing just something
that you have to deal with it's not real
she may not get as much media attention
now that her days on gossip girl are
behind her but momsen is happier with
her career so the trade-off seems to
have been worth it and while momsen does
use social media she tries not to spend
too much time online in general
after going silent for a few years the
pretty reckless finally released their
long-awaited fourth album on february 12
2021. titled death by rock and roll
momsen says that although it might sound
morbid the album sums up their
philosophy on life it's a philosophy
that late producer conduala always
celebrated
living according to your own terms the
album topped the charts during the week
of its release
the fans are what make it i mean we have
the best fans with the loss of condola
it took longer than usual for the band
to pull the album together and they had
to figure out how they were going to
produce the album without him
and who they should work with instead in
addition the covet 19 pandemic prompted
the band to shift the release date
momsen told the daily beast we finished
the album right before kovid and due to
the insane world circumstances we pushed
it a little bit
as soon as it's safe to do so the pretty
reckless is ready to get back on the
road where you might be seeing a lot
more of momsen in the coming years
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call or chat
online with the national suicide
prevention lifeline
at 1-800-273-talk 8255 or text home to
the crisis text line
741 741